here's something that'll really get
under your skin
that's quad colas and judging from these
designs it has a certain geometric Flair
it's amazing
we've come to Paris to meet PRM and
Johan D Siberia
to find out more about this astonishing
invention Oh Ellie the reclamation of a
bra that we in Nam Amanda chose a
securely numeric new Pammy the DNA dish
was tracking PKD cruiser Kinnison
perceived image in illusionary a llama
this is pretty awesome I think I would
get a tattoo from a robot on a statins
obscenity a recruit that was run on a
dog ridiculous Nick dumb question
eliminator a solution and more legit you
have one book with aliens on the FAFSA
mineral race in the new year so how did
this pair amp up a 3d printer to become
a fully fledged tattoo artist by taking
an ordinary 3d desktop printer and
attaching a tattoo gun they've made it
able to reproduce virtually any design
tattooing is more complicated than
normal printing because the human body
isn't a flat surface and so a 3d printer
is actually ideal it can move in three
different directions and perfectly match
the shape of the body part the people
being tattooed are actually straps down
what that's because the 3d tattooing
machine can't tell if they move and so
they need to remain completely
stationary are we sure this is safe guys
the needle in this tattoo gun has been
mechanically constrained which means
hypothetically it's perfectly safe and
of course because it's a machine it
never makes a mistake right right of it
it's a little cheaper don't be annoyed
you
sipping machine que canta morph in Anoka
flowy romantic a judicial Pisa saluted
and a blue foam yeah no one here was
brave enough to let this machine lose
thankfully a prosthetic was on hand to
receive an outrageous tattoo exactly how
we pictured it thanks guys